we had a new mansion and music hot tubs
and tears and ultimately the realization
that the bachelor is quarantine this is
your The Bachelor presents listen to
your heart season 1 episode 1 recap grab
your glasses
it's time for roses and rose they hi
everybody it's me Lauren Zima and how
I've missed you oh here we are in the
quarantine or should I say Corran chic
yes everyone I might be trapped inside
weirdly Chris Harrison's bachelor
mansion but I would not be stopped from
bringing you roses and Rose a look at
our new set we've got florals we've got
fire we've got wine I never thought I
would be recording roses and Rose a from
Chris Harrison's house but we are
quarantine together so here we are as I
told you when we all first started
sipping sheltering in place in tough
times you keep it chic so I'm drinking
my wine today out of a beautiful
Waterford crystal highball glass we've
got to take the little things you know
we've got to keep it positive we've got
to keep it going keep the wine going
literally don't stop yep that feels
right
you know I hate to call out the World
Health Organization they released a
statement that drinking alcohol is not
necessarily a good way to cope during
this global pandemic
[Applause]
yeah not really really not notice I put
on a pant a red sleeve and
off-the-shoulder keep it shake everybody
hello that's our nation The Bachelor
franchise is the gift that keeps on
giving and right off the bat I'm gonna
say I loved listen to your heart episode
1 what did you guys think of the
premiere let me know in the comments
below it felt like The Bachelor but knew
it felt like The Bachelor but
so here we go let's get to it
oh and also I know that you guys want
all these updates on The Bachelorette
well here's the thing things stand as
they stand you know I mean it's
postponed indefinitely because who knows
what's happening this quarantine things
change every day we were supposed to be
six feet away from people never supposed
be like twelve feet away from people and
often those measurements are given to me
in meters then I have to do all the
different three meters and feet it's
like a whole big thing the bottom line
is sing away from be blinders quarantine
with Chris air something thank God he
has a wine cellar
welcome to listen to your heart so I
loved the way things opened we still get
Chris Harrison on that wet driveway it's
a different driveway a different mansion
did you notice no fountain I didn't like
it at first but it grew on me I thought
that it was wrong at first but then I
said why not
it felt horrifying and then okay kind of
like quarantine why did they change
mansions Chris Harrison told me it was
simply because they were gonna have a
lot of people and performances and they
needed more space and everybody let's
drink for how this needs to sink in just
like the alcohol sinking into our bodies
this is the first truly new bachelor
franchise show we have gotten in years
I mean paradise was probably the last
big one and these people don't know each
other right it's kind of wild on
paradise it so you're on battery on
Bachelorette I know you I've seen you
I've Instagram stalked you I hooked up
with you at Coachella you know but here
it's new it's interesting it's different
just like a global pit no boring
everything is not I think it's not about
corona but I've got to point out about
this show is that in the intro Chris
Harrison mentioned a star is born we
hear the bats are all big fans of the
movie a star is born yeah he said the
show is paradise meets Jackson Maine
Dalli you guys he made me a rosy and
then he made me a show
lives will be changed here on this stage
we are wondering how so Chris Harrison
tells us if you're not part of a
committed couple you're going home if
you're not part of a committed couple
you're going home that's like paradise
and each couple will be performing
romantic duet live on stage so that's
like stars born and seemingly at some
point they might kind of sort of be
judged in front of some of the biggest
names in the music industry oh that's
like life okay great so here we are it's
a reality show you know and now I'm
ready for a new adventure with
everything that I'm dealt with and then
we're gonna meet the people because
remember we really don't know them don't
drink for every person you've never seen
we started off strong with a 34 year old
veteran four years in the Marine Corps
and I know he's been through some real
issues
I'm Sheridan Reed I'm 27 years old and
I'm living in Austin Texas there's a guy
who says he's ready to settle down
though I wrote down he seemed to be
largely living out of his car I'm ready
to try to find a copilot for Sheila this
was also the closet at least Dean had a
van
[Music]
and then and then and then we had a
musical-theater gal you deserved love
and she said and I quote I don't exist
without musical theater I don't exist
without musical theater all I've ever
done is performed cheers I felt that
then there's a guy who does Christian
music you know a drink for all the
different types of music blowing through
this alright Holmes I'm 29 years old and
tell me what you guys thought of Trevor
Trevor was not American Idol before so
is he a reality TV show ho anyway let me
know in the comments below
I wrote down oh he's shirtless oh he's
Nick Viall with the dog okay he did say
his dream would be being on a tour bus
with the love of my life though his
dream really is a stars born so you know
here we are Trevor the first person to
arrive feels like absolutely you've got
a lot we also have 21 year old Jamie and
I wrote down she's 21 every guy that
I've ever dated has cheated on me she
says every guy she's ever dated has
cheated on her and I said well Jamie
that's because they were teenagers
look you guys the age thing has been
such a question in the franchise right
and as a reminder the Bachelorette for
Clare Crawley season is now recasting so
you know go ahead and apply and submit
those guys who are a little bit older
who you think could be right for clear
my bottom line is this again I think
that your maturity is about your
experience in life I just think it's
quite quite difficult to in those very
early 20s right out of college right out
of living at home with your parents to
know what you want in a relationship
anyway how lot happens in your twenties
you know the late 20s and mid that's
better I'll fall in love here so Jamie
gets to the mansion and she just seems
like a little
doesn't she you know hi and we just like
oh you're such a little and I'm talking
about her age okay some dude gets to the
mansion and he really doesn't seem to
know the bachelor world he calls Chris
Harrison Chris Hanson
I almost said Chris Hanson it's not
Chris Hanson like the guy from To Catch
a Predator remember that show swami
google it if you don't what a premise
but this is Chris Harrison and I'm in
his home so I know okay Jaime says she
doesn't want a drama
I wouldn't want like some girl to like
walk through the toilets just trying to
start drama like I do not want to deal
with that Jaime get off the show
go home Jaime go home now she doesn't
want to be who wants to be home none of
us anyway oh my god
the man who felt broody really cracked
me up she went and met Chris and he was
like are you really ready are you ready
to possibly find love and she was like
I'm getting ready I'm ready and I'm
ready to sing with hot people I worked
my whole life to be able to sing for a
living
but to be able to do it with hot people
Rudy I love it
like mad and then Rudy says she likes
Matt because he has big arm to do the
mere thought he's attractive and I was
like the biggest arms in the house drink
for all rubies good reasoning again
we're seeing more of the mansion and I
liked it I liked the fire pit vibes
you know I'm by a fire that's why we
have the fire we also have a guitar did
you see that definitely play in that I
don't know how to play guitar anyway Oh
Jaime gosh drink for every time Jamie
and her senses were a little off mm-hmm
she says she's been waiting for this
moment quote for so long for so long
[Music]
tell that to Clara Crawley this is
insane okay oh boo boo was finally gonna
get her season and then a global
pandemic hit some guy starts singing
right away and then he goes in for a
kiss right okay so drink everything he
is doing right away wrong like your lips
Oh way too much whatever that guy's name
is Michael nice to meet I mean there's
no way he's staying right but this is
one of several things that cemented for
me that this new show is a bachelor show
because we got a night one weirdo I made
it okay the guy from Austin is even beer
deist man in franchise history like wow
you know even Jed Wyatt was a musician
Luke Pell was but they were a little
clean-cut this guy I mean I actually
wrote down how do you kiss that you know
I mean I just don't know I love a
stubble the backs of beard drink for
every hair on this face me a refill soon
oh I say that every day okay
welcome to the mansion yeah and then
Chris Harrison arrives so let's go ahead
and drink for all the things that we are
getting that our bachelor things we need
the familiar right now we're in
unprecedented time as we love it we get
a mansion date cards rose ceremonies and
the most critical component Chris
Harrison it's a bachelor show but also
know this one guy even says quote can I
steal her for a minute can I steal her
for a minute it's usually a second boy
here for a minute
thank you so much we find out there are
12 dudes and eight gals gentlemen
there's 12 of you you're handing out the
Roses tonight there's eight of you so
some guys are gonna be going out they're
gonna be told me just like our freedom
what's okay mmm it's important say home
sit by the way thank you everybody who's
been tuning in from group day with Chris
Harrison and I please watch us on Chris
Harrison's Instagram lives we are
donating money to charity for every
episode Andy stay home okay so this show
is moving people are singing people are
talking about people are in the hot tub
yes right away on night one we are
getting people in a hot tub
relationships are really accelerated
aren't they oh god drink every time
quarantine feels like The Bachelor
we're all getting so close we're all
moving in we're all accelerating our
relationships you might move in with
somebody's family that's a hometown hey
you ain't going to the hot tub and and
and that's a fantasy suite
so then Mike or is it Matt Matt yes sir
what is this semi bearded guy's name
he's like he's got a mohawk Matt Mike
Matt Matt Mike is like Ruby we've known
each other for two hours so let's make
out for two hours I've known Rudy and
there's definitely something there so I
think it's an inevitability that we're
gonna probably attack each other with
some kisses I mean it's one thing for a
make-out on night one I listen to your
heart we're getting hot to make out on
night one oh I love the conversation
that Rudy and Matt Mike had in the hot
tub it was cute I got butterflies
watching their butterflies cute I mean
this is the escapism I need which is
weird because these people are also
trapped in a house how meta is the
matrix broken is the simulation flawed
everybody let me know in the comments
below okay and what did you think of
Matt Mike let me know in the comments
below we should wait okay should Ruby
have kissed him let me know in the
comments below but Jamie and Ryan did
kiss it didn't say and it looks like a
lot of tongue right away you know I mean
the best time like literally ever then
Jamie is talking to Trevor again I'm
connecting with Trevor too
and drink every time a star is born is
mentioned obviously you love stars born
yeah now Jamie and Trevor are in the hot
tub and I am getting very invested in
this very quickly is it my quarantine
brain or is this a really good show how
do i quarantine goggles on do these
people have bachelor mansion goggles on
I don't know and I'm ready to go home I
mean Chris Harrison's mansion but I miss
my apartment but he does have all the
wine don't you know that was my falsetto
I think I'm a good singer do you guys
think these people are good singers who
is the best let me know in the comments
below cuz I can't really judge I thought
it was a weird choice I wrote down to
have Stand By Me playing as they made
out they don't interesting to see what
songs we get during all this like what
did they pay for the rights to stand by
me with your tongue in my mouth
Oh make out Jamie it works okay and then
I was confused because now it's the
morning so they're here till the morning
I thought we were sending people home on
night one why did we go in the hot tub
on night one net are we all confused
about how time works are we all confused
about time Ryan
choose someone who makes your heart sing
okay so Ryan gets the date card if he
takes Jamie on the date and I was
actually on this date yes we interviewed
them you can check out those interviews
et online.com shameless button
and we are flying through these dates
Matt Mike is getting a date card through
their map but he doesn't know who he
should take on the day and Rudy says
that her ideal date is to stay home and
make pasta and watch her movie I would
make us pasta and we would watch a scary
movie how things have changed you know
what my ideal date now is just get the
[ __ ] out of here
anywhere I'll go outside do any place
where do you want to take me but in
tough times we keep it cheap no oh and
then Matt Mike Matt Picht Mel for his
date were you surprised let me know in
the comments below okay so Ryan and
Jamie are on their date and it was
pretty uneventful though I did write
down that I liked the song can i
download this is this like the voice and
then they come back to the mansion and
everyone says they're jealous it's not
gonna lie I thought that everybody
seemed more so jealous of the fact that
they got to record a song with a
big-time music producer than over their
love connection
you know what did you think I will be
interested to see if at any point the
show makes people choose like are you
gonna have to choose between your music
career and your love Wow okay a couple
quick things Rudy says she's upset
because Matt Mike was gonna take her on
the date you literally swear and I wrote
down who is this guy who's always on the
piano I love him and I also said Rudy is
amazing
if this is an original song she's
singing anybody if you know let me know
I googled the lyrics I couldn't find it
oh and she's already crying I don't know
okay it's definitely a bachelor show you
don't even uh thing else we are going to
get out of listen to your heart
some influencers who have some of the
best actual content we've had in a while
like they can really sing so great
upping the bachelor influence or
pedigree okay so it's the rose ceremony
and who knows how long it's been out
there or in here or in here that would
be super sad to go home today because I
don't know where I stand and I wondered
what would happen
Janie seemed more into Ryan to me at
this point but Trevor can't go home he's
our biggest star he flirted with Katy
Perry on American Idol it is so hard
what am I talking like this oh you guys
one thing I have loved about the
quarantine is that I don't feel alone
because I have all of my personalities
and you I love you so much thank you for
watching okay so it's rose ceremony
night and everyone is going to sing for
their lives aren't they yes the men are
getting the roses from the women
so Austin beardy guy is singing and Matt
Mike is bumper because he says oh wait
mal who he took on the date is not
actually into his face she likes
somebody else I don't think I'm getting
a rose from mouth this is zero chance
Benny says and I quote let me circle
back with Ruby I'm gonna circle back
with Rudy you are not replying all on an
email you are not bringing this to the
top of someone's inbox you are not
saying can we set up the zoom for a
later time no thanks how about zoom
we're recording this on Zoom wait for it
zoom then Trevor serenades to Jamie I
mean this show should really be called
singing for your live now Jamie and
Trevor are kissing and now she is crying
and talking about living with no regret
just never regrets I said Wow
Jamie she's like I always make the wrong
decision I don't wanna make the wrong
decision well babe yeah you're 21 you've
only made wrong decisions at this point
I feel like I always do
tonight's the rose ceremony the girls
are the ones we're gonna be giving out
the roses and it is the rose ceremony
and oh my goodness wait for it Chris
Harrison's last big piece of advice is
to and I quote listen to your heart
listen to your heart I love it so much
we needed this Jake will you accept this
rose
and shocking things happen at this rose
ceremony Mel said Matt money and gave a
guy named Gabe a rose Matt but Matt
still got a rose from someone I think is
maybe names Cheyenne Cheyenne you know
it's a bachelor show when we don't know
their names at the beginning Wow
is it fun to play with our camera like
this there's no crew here they can't
tell me what to do no crew can't tell me
what to do
can you guys see the glue on my favorite
lashes and then Jamie gives the rose to
Trevor Trevor were you shocked I was
she was just clapping her hands and
saying on paper
Ryan is perfect on paper Ryan is perfect
but I like Trevor I like love being
around Trevor and so that is who I gave
my rose to am i writing a song I love
you Oh somebody cool gave her rose to
Ryan and Ryan's gonna stick around
because anything can happen in the
bachelor world if I could see myself
like playing for some fresh air so some
guys we don't know went home the weird
one with two first names and the skinny
mr. clean and the guy who needs dry
shampoo honestly Who am I to talk I'm
not washing my hair because the grease
keeps the flyaways down and I've got to
be on camera coming up next week oh and
then we get a preview for next week and
rogue people are coming in actually
no Trevor cuz I'm friends with his act
and there are more tears so tired
happiness
oh it's really a bachelor show don't you
know huh everybody we're off the thief
and we're stuck in our houses but I have
to say hey I'm grateful for health care
workers cuz I know they are putting
themselves in a much bigger harm's way
I'm being serious for a minute I know
that I'm drinking my wine and talking
about The Bachelor but I want to thank
everybody who's working so hard to keep
all of us safe and I want to raise a
glass to everyone who is saying at home
and doing their part I love you guys all
so much thank you for watching roses and
Rosie we will be here every week because
I am NOT leaving you in these tough
times okay again in tough times you keep
it oh wait for it Warren chic and so we
are gonna be here I'm gonna be right
here I'll be right getting here okay not
good anywhere
that was weird okay I'm sorry that was
weird listen to your heart when the
quarantine comes just a home it's the
right thing to do hon I don't know where
you're going
but it should be nowhere listen to your
hearts and do not go out there you know
it's great there's wine in here I love
you guys stay home stay safe and I'll
see you next week bye
[Music]